mesdames et messieurs bonsoir dans la
présente édition nous vous parlerons de
politique internationale avec le sommet
franco-africain de rwanda et vous
entendrez aussi bokassa 1er répondre à
ceux qui l'accusent d'avoir laissé
perpétrés récemment un génocide il
s'agit de la mort d'un très grand nombre
d'enfants et d'adolescents dans son pays
suisse le corps électoral adopte la
nouvelle loi nucléaire
vous verrez et les coulisses du grand
meeting tenu hier à marseille par
monsieur georges marchais notre page du
cinéma est consacrée aux grands films
projetés en ce moment à cannes
tiercé l'arrivée c'est un 9 15
vous en aurez les images naturellement
mais nous commencerons par la bicyclette
et le vélo ce n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose on peut dire que la
bicyclette grosso modo c'est le tourisme
et le vélo c'est la course la course
d'abord c'était aujourd'hui bordeaux
paris plus de 580 km par le chemin des
écoliers depuis six ans aucun français
n'avait remporté d'épreuve
et bien c'est chose faite puisque la
victoire est allée à andré chalmel un
breton comme hymne parti seul en tête
quelques kilomètres seulement après la
prise des entraîneurs and a trait au
241e kilomètres le coureur de 6000
guimard va effectuer un fabuleux
cavalier seul jusqu'à l'arrivée à
fontenay réalisant la moyenne
fantastique de 47 km 0 61
une moyenne qui a complètement aux
prises au dépourvu les organisateurs de
l'épreuve
survolté chalmel aspiré par la moto de
son entraîneur joe gutor il mène un
train d'enfer
derrière tout le monde craque seuls deux
hommes résistent dont celui ci herman
van springel super favori de l'épreuve
cinq fois vainqueur
volkswagen c'est ce qu'il fait en 80 km
il a repris de l'épiné il revient à une
43,2 chalmel après avoir compté 6
minutes de retard et là c'est l'accident
idiot 446e kilomètres des problèmes de
dérailleur le mécano qui fait une chute
touche la rousse et la chute inévitable
il est remonté sur le vélo afin de
pringle mais il sait que tout est fini
pour lui avec son entaille au cuir
chevelu c'est le miracle de la volonté
pour le vert
on
et finalement chalmel l'emportent ils le
méritent et c'est un coureur qui
n'hésite pas à faire don de sa personne
en particulier
pour bernard hinault son chef de file de
lépine termine 2e et van springel mais
oui hélas tout même il termine en 3ème
position et bien et du vélo sautons à
bicyclette s'il ya en france 70 coureurs
professionnels et environ 70 mille
coureurs amateurs on estime qu environ
10 millions de français pratiquent la
bicyclette qu'ils appellent
affectueusement la petite reine soit
pour aller à leur travail soit pour
s'entretenir en bonne forme
car c'est un merveilleux moyen de se
conserver en pleine condition physique
aujourd'hui c'était dans à peu près
toutes les villes de france la journée
nationale de la bicyclette organisée par
l'union nationale des deux roues l'an
passé il y avait eu deux cent mille
participants
on pense que cette fois ci il y en a eu
bien davantage en a ras le chiffre exact
demain à paris gérard belmas a suivi des
participants pédaleurs sur l'étape de
montmartre à la porte maillot
les ruelles de la butte sont durs aussi
que le néophyte au mollet blanc ou
briscard des routes de week end car dur
elle a revanche sur l'auto cette
traversée de paris valait bien une butte
et saint christophe à fouler une
multitude de cierges reconnaissant mais
personne ne voulait de la lanterne rouge
et le vent frisquet n'incitait pas à
s'attarder devant les chevalets des
barbouilleurs seule concession au décor
belle époque de la petite reine des
moustaches en guidon de vélo mais marche
un peuple a pas du tout pas du nom vous
savez respecter le contrat alors oui il
toujours vous avez quel âge
[ __ ] quand on fait du vélo toujours et
vous allez ampleur comme chalon vous
avez un danger qui est particulière
oui ce que j'ai à tours du plateau de
montagne expliquez-moi donc l inventaire
quelques dizaines d'enfants un vétéran
de 81 ans mais loin de perdre les
pédales
au total sûrement un millier d'amateurs
ou en voie de développement le vélo
c'est aussi le pied de nez à la crainte
de pénurie de vélo mag bagnols one
marinois et moi des murs y jeudi
l'énergie musculaire c'est l'énergie la
moins chère mais peut-être qu'elle que
soit comprendront que la sagesse vélo
notamment grosse et indique comment nous
les amis de la terre les amis de la vie
écologique
c'est excitant ce n'est pas la hollande
mais la concorde cyclables pour les
clous écolo comme pour les vélos anglais
d'alliages étudié pour comment ne pas
rêver déjà à la journée sans voiture
envisagé en tandem par jeunesse et
sports et diverses associations dont
handisport et ses aveux c'est un sport
qui est à cet instant même pour les
promenades
moi j'ai un problème pendant la
compétition enfants promenades en cyclo
c'est très intéressant pour nous
ce qui incite le paysage il faut qu'il
soit décrit par le dans le guide quoi
l'on sache un peu dans laquelle on
repasse aujourd'hui plus qu'hier et
moins que demain bien des français
notamment avenue de la grande armée
avait un petit vélo en tête celui de la
liberté et de l'air politique demain
sourd à kigali rwanda la conférence
franco africaines que présidera
monsieur giscard d'estaing de très
nombreux chefs d'état et de gouvernement
prennent part aux travaux où l'on note
pour la première fois les représentants
du liberia un pays de langue anglaise
nous rejoignons meurice werther notre
envoyé spécial qui gagne en principe il
n'y a pas d'ordre du jour en fait on va
surtout parler d'affaires économiques
coopération et développement les
affaires de sécurité qui avaient dominé
et inquiéter la conférence franco
africaine de paris il y a un an sont
maintenant passés au deuxième et même
carrément au dernier plan souvenez vous
il y a un an les crises d'afrique était
au paroxysme ethiopie erythrée chabat
mauritanie on ne veut pas dire cette
année que tout soit réglé mais enfin il
ya moins d'urgence
au contraire la situation économique de
beaucoup des participants est plutôt
préoccupante
le meilleur exemple en est le minuscule
rwanda pays hôte dont on imagine mal le
dénouement lorsqu'on envoie les riantes
colline l'aide et la coopération
française ils sont exemplaires
un simple chiffre met syfy katif 37
millions de francs dead en 1978 pour des
projets réalistes de mise en valeur
agricole par exemple quand on parlera
politique ce sera en famille comme a dit
l'un
les participants une famille avec ses
grands noms sans bord du sénégal ou
fouette de côte d'ivoire mobutu du zaïre
une famille soucieuse de ne pas tomber
sous la coupe ou dans l'orbité des
supers grandes puissances et qu'il y
assez bien réussi jusqu'à présent
une famille dont les membres évite de se
quereller de peur de se voir reprocher
de se mêler de ce qui ne le regarde pas
ce qui est la conception très stricte
des africains du principe de la non
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
mais si l'on doit être regardé sans
indulgence certains ponts la conduite
scandalise
il ne faut pas s'attendre que la
conférence condamne l'empereur bokassa
s'il vient à kigali et bien justin
bokassa 1er empereur comme il dit de
centrafrique est arrivé à qui guette
tout le monde naturellement lui a posé
des questions sur l'horrible massacre
d'enfants et d'adolescents qui est
accusée d'avoir laissé perpétrer en
avril dans son pays
voici ses explications moi j'ai eu de la
peine pour cette campagne de dénigrement
de calomnies ce qui est fait que j'ai
quand même été soldat et je vais vous
dire que le principe que toutes les
armées du monde
même lorsqu'il est une guerre c'est
d'épargner les enfants épargné les
femmes épargnez les vieillards on ne
touche pas aux enfants
on ne touche pas aux femmes on ne touche
pas à l'ouvrir et dire que moi qui est
père de famille nombreuse que j'aime
attaquer les enfants vraiment c'est
assez dur à supporter il faudrait que
les justifications soient faites pas ce
que je veux bien les connaître toutes
les fautes mais pas elle
je suis chrétien j'ai reçu mon baptême
appelé jeunes enfants et l'abbé brand
qui m'a baptisé aujourd'hui les évêques
et les paies strasbourg j'ai réduit ma
confirmation à lourdes
je suis un gros club vient renonce de la
concurrence elle même
il faut souligner que c'est la première
fois qu'un sommet franco africain se
réunit d'ailleurs qu'à paris ou dans une
ancienne colonie de la france
sa présence d'un observateur du libéria
ou division tout à l'heure témoigne
aussi de la volonté d'ouverture de paris
dans ses rapports avec le continent noir
avec bernard rapp le point de la
politique africaine de la france
trois idées résume assez bien la
le président de la république a donné un
nom à la première c'est le trial hoc
si vous préférez un dialogue à trois
dans lequel interviennent aux côtés de
la france l'europe en tant que tel et le
monde arabe
c'est cette idée que valéry giscard
d'estaing exposera à nouveau demain à
kigali
cette sorte de partage de la coopération
préconisée par la france tient compte
des réalités politiques nouvelles
l'europe d'abord qui se construit sous
nos yeux peut et doit intervenir en tant
que tel en afrique et elle le fait déjà
dans le domaine économique avec le
marché commun le monde arabe ensuite
dont la puissance n'est plus à démontrer
a lui aussi son mot à dire et il en a
les moyens
enfin l'afrique elle-même a beaucoup
changé elle a pris du poids sur la scène
internationale ces leaders sont
aujourd'hui écouter ses richesses
naturelles convoitées et l'aide se fait
devenues plus exigeantes mais
précisément en même temps qu'ils
évoluent est le continent africain est
devenu le champ clos où s'affrontent les
grandes puissances l'intervention
cubaine en angola ainsi créé une
véritable psychose de déstabilisation
dans les pays d'afrique modérée alors
pour y remédier c'est le second aspect
de la politique française en afrique le
président français a décidé il a dit
clairement de répondre à l'appel à
l'aide de ses amis africains menacé il
l'a fait au tchad il l'a fait en
mauritanie et dans des conditions un peu
différente au zaïre
c'est ce que l'on a appelé la stratégie
du jaguar du nom des avions français
engagés dans le ciel africain
enfin dernier volet de cette politique
africaine de paris
la paire s'est opérée par la france en
afrique anglophone
un exemple celui du nigeria qui avait 80
millions d'habitants est aujourd'hui
notre cinquième fournisseur de pétrole
avant l'algérie
l'une des principales personnalités de
la vie politique espagnole monsieur
felipe gonzalez secrétaire-général du
pse et le parti socialiste briller
l'espagne a décidé de ne plus tenir ce
poste en effet il venait d'être mise en
minorité m us à l'aise souhaitait que
son parti ne s'affirme à plus comme
marxiste
la majorité des délégués au congrès du
pse et en a jugé autrement
elle a conservé cette étiquette donc
monsieur d'un salaire sans élections
européennes comment avait vidé avec
quatre grandes formations se
comporte-t-il dans leurs innombrables
déplacement en sommes derrière la
personnalité politique
l'homme où la femme nous vous avons déjà
présenté madame simone veil et monsieur
jacques chirac
voici monsieur georges marchais suivi
hier dans son grand meeting de marseille
par jean-louis de serre marseille
capitale de l'eurocommunisme l'espace
d'un après midi comme turin le sera
demain en recevant georges marchais
c'était hier ici à marseille le premier
grand meeting commun en france depuis
celui de la porte de pantin en juin 1976
plusieurs milliers de personnes entre
15000 et 20000 selon les observateurs
des militants venus des quatre coins du
sudes du languedoc du vaucluse et même
même de l'isère ils ont attendu trois
quarts d'heure dans le bande s et sous
un ciel de plomb
l'arrivée des dirigeants communistes
stand fanfare cracheurs de feu
personnages de carnaval au stade
vélodrome de marseille
hier il y avait en petit l'ambiance
animée que connaissent bien ceux qui
fréquentent la fête de l'humanité
georges marchais est un passionné troppo
un point tel qu'il est capable de vous
dire parker qui en 56 étaient dans les
filets de sedan lorsque ce club a battu
la n 3 en finale de coupe de france
inutile de dire que hier le leader du
parti communiste jubilait d'avoir à
pénétrer sur un stade par le fameux
tunnel en compagnie d'éric oberlinger
etc gorille mais la politique rapidement
a repris ses droits et notamment la
politique européenne
ce n'est pas un mystère
il existe entre les deux parties des
divergences et des orientations
différentes sur des problèmes importante
des politiques européennes telles que
celui de l'élargissement de la
communauté à la grèce à l'espagne au
portugal auxquels nous sont favorables
ou les problèmes des pouvoirs du
parlement européen dont nous pensons
qu'ils doivent être renforcées les
parties chrétiennes
pour georges marchais fini les foucades
les petites phrases et le ton mort que
des débats radio télévisés pour parler
des divergences entre partis communistes
français et italiens jamais il n'a levé
les yeux hier du texte qui lui avait été
écrit jamais il n'a changé un mot quand
il le faut le secrétaire général du pc
c'est être diplômé sur ce dernier
chacun peut pendant que je rappelle à
marseille la préoccupation qui est celle
de notre parti de préserver les intérêts
des travailleurs et des paysans de notre
pays
en même temps que de sauvegarder des
dispositions qui garantissent que les
décisions prises à la majorité ne puisse
être imposée à notre peuple à nos
régions à notre nation
deux bêtes de scène georges marchais a
su depuis quelque temps se muer en
rassembleur des meetings un tout autre
métier
mais monsieur marché c'est bien
aujourd'hui que cela peut payer comme on
dit pour preuve le seul meeting d'hier a
rapporté 160 adhésion à la fédération
communiste des bouches du rhône 160
adhésion qui pour la plupart ont été
enregistrées pour le compte de chômeurs
du complexe sidérurgique de fausses des
chantiers navals de la ciotat et de la
scène où des mineurs de gardanne
notre confrère le figaro publie demain
une longue interview de monsieur
françois mitterrand le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste explique
que le président de la république est
contraint de changer de majorité
j'ai longtemps pensé dit encore monsieur
françois mitterrand que jacques chirac
avait intérêt à précipiter les élections
législatives
je me demande maintenant si ce n'est pas
valéry giscard d'estaing qui a intérêt à
le faire
en attendant les deux partis de la
majorité continue à faire patauger la
france dans leur appui sens comme une
fin de citation deux importants rendez
vous de politique et de télévision
demain lundi aussitôt après le journal
c'est à dire à 20h30 troisième émission
spéciale élections europe diffusé
conjointement par antenne 2 et par
europe numéro 1 madame simone veil et
monsieur françois mitterrand seront les
invités de ce programme
jean pierre elkabbach à etienne
mougeotte animeront des débats auxquels
participeront également d'autres
journalistes des deux rédactions et le
surlendemain c'est à dire ce mercredi
qui vient 23 mai est toujours à 20h30
nouvel événement du même ordre puisque
antennes d'europe numéro un vous
proposeront l'autre rencontre européenne
c est monsieur jacques chirac et
monsieur georges marchais qui seront
leurs invités le débat est animé comme
celui de demain donc deux points forts
de politique et de télévision cette
semaine il y avait aujourd'hui en suisse
un double référendum le projet sur
l'instauration de la tva
adopté par le gouvernement et le
parlement a été rejetée par à peu près
neuf cent mille électeurs contre 500
milles mais la loi sur l'implantation
des centrales nucléaires ont posé par le
gouvernement helvétique est acceptée par
le parlement
a été approuvé par le corps électoral à
la majorité des deux tiers
un million de lecteurs pour un peu moins
de 450 milles contre c'était elle la
première loi sur le nucléaire proposé
par un pays européen
depuis l'accident il ya quelques
semaines à risberg aux états unis qui
n'a donc pas eu par une rapide analyse
que l'on peut faire en attendant demain
l'impact attendu sur le corps électoral
suisse à supposer qu'un accident arrive
à des installations nucléaires en france
comment pourrait-on intervenir denise
boisvert vous présente une cellule
mobile d'intervention mis en place par
la sécurité civile de brignoles de
brignoles dans le var
chaque jour en france des matériaux
radioactifs circulent par voie routière
ou ferroviaire
ils sont destinés aux besoins des
hôpitaux ou aux industries et des
accidents peuvent arriver
c'est pour cela que la sécurité civile
de brignoles dans le var a formé une
cellule mobile d'intervention
radiologique quatre hommes la composent
elle est la première de france
le commissariat à l'énergie atomique a
assuré la formation de ces militaires en
cas d'accident il testerait la
contamination et isolerait la zone
polluée leur rôle s'arrête là ce serait
aux techniciens de l'énergie atomique
d'intervenir ensuite avec des moyens
plus puissant mais pour l'heure les
hommes de brignoles s'entraîne
pour eux on a simulé un accident un
colis radioactifs est tombé d'un train
première urgence isolé la source
radioactive
jerry seah à l'aide de détecteurs qu'il
n'y a pas eu de pollution alentours
puis s'assurer que personne n'a été
contaminé faire appel le cas échéant aux
médecins spécialistes de l'énergie
atomique
s'il y avait des soins à donner la zone
de pollution une fois délimité et isoler
les volontaires de brignoles ont
accompli leur mission dans les prochains
mois les sapeurs pompiers recevront avec
l'aide de l'edf la même formation il y
aura alors 13 cellules opérationnelles
sur le territoire
a phoenix dans l'arizona aux etats-unis
non loin de la montagne sacrée vivent et
travaillent des indiens de lavage aux
une averse il ne s'agit pas d'une
réserve loin de là mais deux mines
notamment de mines de charbon
présenté par philippe gassot voici ce
que j'appellerais une histoire
typiquement américaine à quelques
kilomètres de la montagne sacrée des
navarro la plus grande réserve des états
unis est en train de subir une nouvelle
conquête cette fois au nom de l'énergie
les indiens sont divisés sur le bien
fondé des concessions faites au progrès
et dénonce par exemple la construction
d'une centrale électrique sur leurs
terres qui fonctionne avec leur charbon
pour subvenir aux besoins de la ville de
phoenix la ville des blancs dépositaire
selon les experts de 80 % de l'uranium
et d'au moins 10% du charbon des états
unis il faut en période de crise compter
maintenant avec les indiens qui se
montre parfois très réticents je pense
que les vieux et les jeunes ne veulent
pas entendre parler du développement
dans les réserves
c'est probablement ce qui se trouve
entre les deux qui veulent
l'exploitation du charbon de l'uranium
du pétrole du gaz et tout ça je ne pense
pas que les indiens soit assez prudent
qu'on leur terre parce que ils
détruisent toutes les terres et pour les
indiens la terre c'est leur mère
nous devons garder nos ressources
naturelles pour le peuple indien
beaucoup d'hommes blancs déjà pris nos
terres je pense que nous devons garder
ce qui nous reste et l'utiliser pour
nous mêmes pourtant malgré l'opposition
l'attend
les chefs élus des indiens ont signé
avec les grandes compagnies américaines
des contrats d'exploitation qui devrait
se multiplier
il convient de préciser que la loi
permet au gouvernement des états unis
d'utiliser les ressources des réserves
en cas de crise aiguë
il est apparu sans doute préférable de
traiter avec les trusts
à black mesa où les réserves sont
estimées à 400 millions de tonnes seppi
badie la plus grande compagnie de
charbonnages des états unis qui
contrôlent la production
le charbon navarro est de très bonne
qualité et passivement accessible les
accords ont été conclus pour dix ans les
grands moyens sont employés pour aller
vite on ne sait pas de quoi demain sera
fait
si dragline sont en service chacune de
ces machines coûtent 1 milliard de
centimes
250 millions de dollars
tous les accords passés avec les indiens
ont été avalisées par le ministère de
l'intérieur à washington pour le
président jimmy carter là où il
représente une des solutions aux
problèmes du pétrole et il a décidé de
favoriser les transformations de
centrales à fuel en centrales au charbon
60% des usines réparties dans les états
sont susceptibles d'être adapté aux
nouvelles normes ou satan ici a en
quelque sorte un nouvel âge du charbon
il y a un excellent avenir pour le
charbon en ce moment il y assez de
charbon a brûlé pour 300 ans je ne parle
pas que de cette main il y a près de
2000 d exploitation aux états unis si
les traditions ensemble en péril les
tribus indiennes touche de peabody ici 1
milliard 600 millions de centimes par an
les plus hautes royalty jamais versés
indique la compagnie de plus 86 % des
employés sont navarro sur les 900
employés que compte la mine
pour quelques-uns le niveau de vie a
augmenté et devient comparable à celui
des non indiens mais il s'éloigne aussi
par le mode de vie de la grande majorité
qui est encore loin de la manne du
charbon ou de l'uranium et qui vit
encore dans les conditions les plus
misérables des états unis accrochés à
des traditions que les chefs des tribus
eux mêmes ont accepté d'adapter à la
nouvelle situation en faisant jouer aux
réserves le rôle de pays exportateurs
retour à paris pour un défilé celui des
floralies internationales
elle se déroule vous le savez avec un
vif succès dans le parc floral de
vincennes
mais aujourd'hui douze chars fleuris ont
traversé la capitale sous la conduite de
pierre figeac commissaire général depuis
l'hôtel de ville où le départ avait été
donné par madame bernadette chirac
jusqu'à la nation par la république et
la bastille les fleurs étaient offertes
par la fédération nationale des
producteurs de l'horticulture et des
pépinières chaque char représentait une
région une telle manifestation n'avait
pas eu lui à paris depuis plus de 20 ans
les floralies dure jusqu'au 5 juin
allez-y c'est super rubrique cinéma au
festival de cannes le film de francis
ford coppola
excusez-moi a très vivement impressionné
ce qu'ils ont vu son titre apocalypse
now l'histoire est librement adapté
d'une nouvelle de joseph conrad au coeur
de la nuit qui se situent en afrique
coppola lui a transporté le sujet au
vietnam
le metteur en scène estime que son fils
n'est pas terminée et il se pose même
question à son propos ne sachant qu'ils
répondraient à inviter le public cannois
à l'aider en lui projetant son oeuvre
gratuitement dans un cinéma de la ville
voici un reflet de cette projection
et maintenant quand à l'heure des six il
aurait été étonnant que la vie d'elvis
presley n'inspirait pas les cinéastes et
bien c'est chose faite avec une minutie
particulièrement méritoire le jeune
acteur courte russell s'est attaché à
restituer l'image vivante de l'idole
disparue son film présenté à cannes mais
hors de compétition du festival a séduit
et le public et les professionnels et
cette similitude de réaction ne se
produit pas toujours pour vous permettre
de juger voici quelques images du film
et les commentaires le contre celles
recueillies par georges bigot
et bakou
non
je suis
allez-vous connu personnellement elle va
se passer iam est là aussi les
rencontrer en 1962 dans un film c'était
la première film que j'ai fait c'était
la ville de lys pressé je voulais savoir
quelle grande leçon pour retirer de la
ville et nos espaces et aux canaux glace
c'est le cas du dieu rama yade espaces
distincts
je ne crois jamais sa vie est dure à
vivre un instant jamais de créations
sous ce mois que j'ai appris
personnellement de grégoire par ce que
j'ai appris à son sujet et 8e sopra qui
le donnait tellement populaire que le
mois ce qui la fait qu'il a créé un
monstre qu'elle ne pouvait plus il a
essayé de s'en tirer mais ça n'a pas
marché
moi je vous dis pas vu comme ça est-ce
que vous pensez que le temps de ces
monstres sacrés tels qu elle vise le
très mauvais encore exister un examen à
l'entrée
non je ne crois pas non plus qu'il
valait plus que tout ce qu'on peut
réaliser dans la pop music aujourd'hui
même dans ses commentaires
tout l'été laurel tel point que ça c'est
tellement différent dans le genre de
choc crois pas que pour pour le public
du monde vraiment un événement très
important pour la nouvelle
on se laisse en volume
en mode sport mardi prochain et grande
fête du volley ball à paris au stade
pierre de coubertin
c'est une journée de propagande pour les
prochains championnats d'europe chevaux
et bien le tiercé secours est à
longchamp dans le prix du journal du
dimanche la victoire est allée à la haye
- c'est-à-dire le cheval qui porte le
plus gros poids de son handicap
il s'agit des verts gold appartenant à
l'écurie search pad kof
celle là même qui avait remporté l'an
passé plusieurs grandes courses aux
états unis avec la jument ça n'aide pas
sur le tiercé le reportage de pierrette
brès nous prenons le déroulement de la
course à l'entrée de la ligne droite
carino a pris le commandement talonné
par royal pinacle tour à tour et a glané
reco royal pinacle vers gold attaque
maintenant karina qui a toujours
l'avantagé marabout semble revenir
facilement mais servat les american
honey le dépasse
la lutte est sévère pinacle réserve al
c'est le deuxième tiers c'est
consécutifs gagnés par ailleurs goal
double bravo à son jeune entraîneur
olivier douieb 1,9 des cases c'est un
p'tit tiercé qui rapporte dans l'ordre
et pour cinq francs 1 3290 francs et
dans le désordre pour 5 francs 6 158
francs
ensuite le prix saint-alary qui se
discutait sur 2000 mètres qui réunissait
les meilleures pouliches âgées de 3 ans
strict rôle casse monté par freddy head
prouve à une fois de plus sa supériorité
en battant nettement pitt asia prochaine
étape pour la grande championne et la
famille head le prix de diane le 10 juin
à chantilly
mais la course la plus spectaculaire fut
le prix du cadran réservée aux chevaux
d'âge qui devaient s'affronter sur 4000
m chang à museau anima toute la course
et tenter l'impossible en prononçant
mètres d'avancé sur ses adversaires
mais la victoire revient finalement à el
badr que monter henry samani c'est une
première victoire classique pour le
propriétaire namouh dfi stocks
et bien voici le bulletin météo
maintenant demain dans la matinée le
temps sera couvert avec des pluies
intermittentes sur l'ensemble du pays
ce n'est que dans l'après midi que l'on
verra apparaître le soleil de la
bretagne et de la normandie à
l'aquitaine
temps gris persistant sur le reste du
pays les vents souffleront fort de
secteur ouest sur les côtes de la manche
notre édition est terminée n'oubliez pas
à les dernières informations du soir
tout à l'heure vers 23h votre édition de
la mi journée demain et vous retrouverez
à 21 patrick papot belle soirée